il est 10 heures à la clinique des
franciscaines de versailles le
neurochirurgien jean-françois le peintre
cofondateur du centre francilien de judo
vient de terminer une intervention
chirurgicale
un patient souffrant du dos c'est un
patient qui avait une instabilité
vertébrale avec ce qu'on appelle un
spondylolisthésis et qui veut dire un
glissement entre deux vertèbres la
troisième vertèbre était instable sur la
quatrième vertèbre qu'on a stabilisé
derrière et qu'on a enlevé ce disque qui
quittent faisaient partie d'instabilité
qu'on l'a remplacé par un implant qui va
stabiliser l'ensemble en créant un pont
ou ceux entre les deux vertèbres en fait
le système devant ici qui est celui
qu'on a mis en place la troisième
lambert la quatrième revers à la
cinquième lombaire
le patient est arrivé le matin et repart
le soir même du centre hospitalier
l'opération se déroule sous anesthésie
générale plusieurs outils technologiques
sont utilisés objectif faciliter le
travail du chirurgien le war mettant
cette machine qui va être positionné au
dessus et autour du patient et qui
robotisé pour regagner des positions de
travail qui sont programmées en début
d'intervention qui nous sert finalement
acquérir en trois dimensions la halle et
d'image
en position opératoire de la colonne
vertébrale du patient ces systèmes de
navigation il va nous permettre de
travailler en temps réel avec un
repérage tridimensionnel sur la colonne
vertébrale du patient sans avoir besoin
d'une grande ouverture et en étant
beaucoup moins agressif puisque comme on
ouvre - on a moins de douleurs
postopératoires on a beaucoup moins de
saignements de risque de saignement
beaucoup beaucoup moins de risques
d'infection plusieurs outils sont
connectés à un système de navigation les
manipulations sont visibles directement
sur l'écran objectif retirer le disque
pathologique pour permettre
l'installation de l'implant entre deux
vertèbres
on doit calibre et tout ça pour remettre
le bon un plan donc là on a un fantôme
de 12 mm de haut de 55 mm de long ça va
nous donner le gabarit de l'implant
définitif qu'on va mettre en place
créée en 2010 le centre francilien du
dos est composé de sept chirurgiens une
équipe complémentaire pour intervenir
sur l'ensemble de la colonne vertébrale
à travers différentes chirurgie c'est au
ce et neurologiques en fait hein ça
concerne la colonne vertébrale
cervicales
thoracique aussi même si c'est moins
fréquent mais beaucoup moins de problème
en thoracique et puis lombaires
ou c'est fréquent des choses simples que
tout le monde connaît comme les hernies
discales par exemple aux choses un peu
plus complexe avec deux des problèmes
d'arthrose stabilité les fractures les
traumatismes les tumeurs de vertèbres
pour la troisième année consécutive le
centre francilien du dos a obtenu la
première place du palmarès des hôpitaux
et des cliniques catégorie chirurgie du
dos un classement publié dans le
magazine du point